c'est suffisamment rare pour être
soulignée l'igpn semble n'avoir eu
d'autre choix que de conclure à une
disproportion de l' usage de la force
par la police
tout part de ces images datées du 23
mars 2019 à nice lors d'une charge des
forces de l'ordre en direction d'un
petit groupe de manifestants
genève le gué 73 ans drapeaux pacifistes
en main chute lourdement
elle sera hospitalisée avec des côtes
cassées et des fractures au niveau du
crâne
à l'époque la sphère fait grand bruit au
point qu emmanuel macron est invité à
réagir ces mots ne vont pas calmer les
esprits je souhaite d'abord qu'elle se
rétablisse au plus vite et sorte
rapidement de l'hôpital et je souhaite
la quiétude à sa famille mais pour avoir
la quiétude
il faut avoir un comportement
responsable quand on est fragile qu'on
peut se faire bousculer on ne se rend
pas dans des lieux qui sont définies
comme interdit et on ne se met pas dans
des situations comme celle-ci pour les
manifestants le cas de geneviève legay
illustre ce qu'ils dénoncent depuis des
mois un usage parfois disproportionné de
la force lors du maintien de l'ordre en
manifestation cette thèse longtemps
réfutés par les autorités vient d'être
approuvé par l'igpn qui vise notamment
l'homme à la manoeuvre lors de cette
charge le commissaire divisionnaire
rabah souchi selon les éléments dévoilés
par mediapart qui cite l'igpn les ordres
donnés par le commissaire divisionnaire
sushis sont inadaptés en particulier
lors de la charge effectuée au cours de
laquelle madame le gars était poussé un
désaveu pour le commissaire
divisionnaire lui qui a défendu ses
agissements par une obligation de
résultat et par ge site
une situation qui se tendaient pour en
attester le commissaire fait état de
manifestants qui chantaient la
marseillaise et refusaient de quitter
les lieux
une caractérisation de tension
croissante qui ne semble pas partagée
par un capitaine de gendarmerie dans ce
rapport dévoilé par mediapart
rabah souchi est présenté comme
particulièrement nerveux notamment parce
que le capitaine de gendarmerie en
question refuse de lancer une charge
contre une foule qu'il qualifie de calme
il indique à son collaborateur proche de
lui qu un capitaine de gendarmerie refus
ses ordres je ne dis rien je n'ai pas
envie de me confronter à un individu
qui ne se maîtrisent plus et qui devient
même presque dangereux dans ce même
rapport le capitaine de gendarmerie
revient sur la charge des policiers
qu'ils observent de près lui aussi parle
de disproportion la charge est effectué
dans les conditions que vous avez pu
voir sur les différentes chaînes
télévisées d'information en totale
disproportion est nécessité face à une
foule d'une trentaine de personnes assez
âgées très calme avec de nombreux
journalistes
pas de gaz lacrymogène des sommations
d'emploi de la force uniquement et une
charge commandé par lui-même instantanée
brutale et violente qui occasionnera
l'incident que vous connaissez nous
sommes tous abasourdis
face à tant d'éléments l'igpn ne pouvait
que conclure à une disproportion
manifeste de la charge qui a blessé et
geneviève le guet une conclusion qui
intervient après plusieurs mois de
controverses autour de ce dossier
puisque le procureur de la république de
nice avait initialement confié l'enquète
à hélène pedneault ya qui non seulement
avait participé à l'opération de
maintien de l'ordre ce jour là mais qui
se trouve en plus être la compagne du
commissaire divisionnaire rabah souchi
de quoi ajouter un peu plus de confusion
dans cette affaire devenue très
politique
reste à voir maintenant quelles seront
les suites pour le commissaire
divisionnaire rabah souchi qui avait été
décoré en juin 2019 par le ministre de
l'intérieur lors d'une promotion
surnommé promotion gilet jaune